who's winning today and there's a
question to everybody by the way Tyler
think about this as well tell him I'm
coming to you as well you've been around
longer than we have who's winning today
is is the right pulling people more to
the right winning today is the center
holding this thing are they being tipped
to the left or to the right or is the
left winning more trying to drag people
to their side
you wanna you wanna hit that one time
hunger no I'll keep yeah thank you very
much I appreciate that
um a little difference here you know age
before beauty is what he's trying to say
Tom all right can I answer eventually
the um so I look at a couple things and
just real real quick
I've been looking at differentials in
voter registrations for the last like
three months and there is you're seeing
it in college students you're nodding
you know something that I'm talking
about I definitely know the Florida
version it's about five percent ahead
for
um you know Independence and Republicans
right now versus Dems and even if you
take the independence out which you
would understand why a lot of people are
jumping to the middle like that you
still have Republicans are ahead on
voter registrations right now going in
the midterm election so I think that is
a sign of what's kind of winning as the
new voters are registering let me add
one thing on that which is the Florida
numbers that you guys can check me as
I'm saying it so I get the numbers
roughly right but uh I heard this had to
say this last week that Florida
basically before him had a 200 000
deficit on the Republican side in terms
of registered voters I think they're up
80 000 now that's two ways yeah so
that's that's a huge we can check the
exact numbers but that's a huge huge
shift right there that so that's one
thing I would also say that the you know
the left right thing sort of doesn't
make sense anymore because Trump came in
and crushed the system to a point that
people who were traditionally
conservatives started sounding like
liberals liberals started especially now
sounds like the craziest authoritarians
so left right doesn't make sense to me
anymore in the in the specific sense I
usually try to say you're either
authoritarian or libertarian and what I
mean by that is you're not a Libertarian
meeting I'm a card-carrying member of
the libertarian party and I run around
naked on stage you know demanding that
nobody has driver's licenses but you
either believe in individual liberty you
can figure out the best way to live your
life and the government should basically
stay out of the way and do some minimal
stuff and that's it or you believe in
the machine you believe that some
machine if we just gave it enough money
and enough power and enough purview over
all of our ability to think and act and
everything else that somehow us giving
all of that power to that thing could
somehow govern us better than we can
actually go govern ourselves so that
makes more sense to me rather than left
right or democrat versus Republican
because none of JFK would be a
republican now no question about he
would be a republican he was cutting
taxes he was anti-war right he he had he
was a patriot
um he was hated by the machine and maybe
the machine killed him you talked to
Oliver Stone I mean you know right so so
those the whole thing has shifted in a
really bizarre way but to answer who
who's winning
um I think the right broadly if we're
just using the right left thing uh is is
really starting to win I think the woke
thing is so out of control this nonsense
don't say gay stuff the critical race
stuff they're attacking people's
children now it was one thing to Glock
people in their homes confuse them about
economics all of that stuff but when you
see cities burning and the riots that we
had by the way we don't you know it's
really odd since Trump left we don't
have race riots anymore it's almost as
if there maybe was some coordination
with someone yeah it's Alex Jones a lot
of stuff you know
um but I think they've gone so far on
everything so far in everything a
Supreme Court Justice nominee can't say
what a woman is it's so bananas that I
think average people are just like I've
had enough of this and and what that
leaves you with is what I say on my show
all the time you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]